well congratulations on this movie guys
it's one thing to have chemistry
another thing to have comedic timing
with some and I read you guys almost
went on like a first date what was this
first date what did it was part of this
first date like let's decide and we she
walks in with common and I'm like the
coolest pad coming in amen oh man we
talked it up and then those guys came
then there's like you were the best
wingman sounds like leaving types she's
not big time you would be more than that
stunt of you hanging off the banner that
was all you right doing that yeah it was
a lot of me yeah it was fun for me you
know I plank I'm a plank
so it was like yeah yeah I was more
concerned like how many takes was that
man another like the big physical thing
in this movie is is you're dancing it's
just phenomenal
are you do you want to spell that you're
a better dancer than that than you are
in this movie was that was that natural
[Laughter]
music I ganked my hips gone cuz your
work on the rap album - Sly Cooper get
roads in the music video oh I would love
to give
I'm not really working on the floor okay
now for album movies in this movie like
me and Mel are trying to get into debt
do you guys remember what ruler was that
really got you at a debt like you
realize like going I can make money
doing this like not just a break but
like you can be like like what was the
rule for you guys you're like okay I'm
good now
I didn't may be called Wicker Park back
in like 20 years ago and that was the
first time I got I was like oh I can
afford to get that thing or whatever
word and that was with yeah you know now
finish I called the Carmichael show oh
yeah yeah and now that's when I was like
okay I mean even though I was like
making you know like seventy five
hundred a week doing a ton of Perry
series but there Carmichael money that
Network go ahead and get my
I get the break space I'm getting new
replacement break and I'm getting brand
new tires not the use tires